foreign
[Music]
let's open up the doors to daily with
Doc my name is Becca dukes and I
absolutely loved
because not only were we streaming uh on
three different platforms yesterday but
today
we have just opened up the floodgates
thank you to one of our co-hosts and our
assistant executive production manager
who is also our lead social media
manager who has just made it absolutely
possible for us to go now on
I counted 12 but you were mentioning
just a few minutes ago AJ that we're on
a couple others that I didn't have on my
list so folks wherever you want to go
find daily with Doc you're gonna find
daily with Doc my name is Becca dukes
and as the hostess of daily with Doc I
am super excited to be able to bring
this empowering information to you
folks we do not have to be slaves to any
system we have it within ourselves when
we know the information when we have the
information
to take control of Our Lives
and that's what this program is all
about it's about giving you tools to put
in your toolbox to help you with each
and every
minute of the life because think about
it we are continually creating cells
within the body
and this program is going to help you
get that information that then
educate you on how to make sure those
cells are the healthiest they absolutely
can be because as we're generating
it takes more than just air
carbohydrates fats and proteins
so just want to make sure all of you
know that and I want to welcome
everybody who is here live with us in
our Zoom they have gone to daily with
Doc zoom.com
and have joined us here live and some of
the benefits of joining us here live are
if you have a question in regards to a
situation that you are a loved one are
going through and you want to know a
more natural holistic nutritional
approach this is the place to get it
because folks not only are we into you
know the natural stuff but the reason
why we're into this natural stuff is
because of the work and research and
clinical applications that the doctor
that we host on this program has done
over the decades I mean decades folks
we're talking at least well 50 decades
that he has been or five decades just
checking
make sure you're paying attention five
decades that he has actually been making
recommendations and
saving Humanity
whether it's the human kind of humanity
or
the animal kind
they're not Humanity but you get my
drift right you don't have to be perfect
to do this job folks so thank you so
much for bearing with me as we are
getting set up
to share some incredible information now
if you were shared this program by
somebody specific we want to make sure
that you get back with them and give
them a great big high five thank you hug
whatever it is that you do to show
appreciation for sharing this
information with you because folks it
changed my life
and I know that if you're paying
attention or if somebody sent you to
watch this program for a reason
but there is a reason and it could
absolutely be instrumental in changing
your life as well so listen up quick get
back with that person that share this
program with you if there is nobody to
think I do have an amazing team of
health coaches who have a passion for
health who have been trained in the
teachings of the doctor that we have on
this program
and not only a passion for health but a
passion for people
and helping people reach their optimal
best we can be reached at
855-949-3377 or through our website
daily withdoc.com use that contact
option and you can reach out to us
through email there we also have our
newsletter make sure that you are signed
up for our newsletter as we will be
sending out a Weekly Newsletter that
shares information about our previous
programs from the previous week or weeks
with the description so it makes it easy
for you to be able to go back and
reference and share
information that you feel is pertinent
to somebody and their own well-being
that you have in your life okay
so with that all being said the FDA does
require us to let you know that our
program is for educational purposes only
and it is on the importance of nutrition
folks because when you give your body
what it needs the body is able to do
something that doctors can't do
the body is able to take that nutrition
put it to work so that it it can
function more effectively
we're not chemical deficient or nutrient
deficient so let's give our body the
nutrients that it needs the FDA does
require us to let you know that our
products are not meant to treat diagnose
cure any diseases
but again
there's over 600 different diseases that
are linked specifically to nutritional
deficiencies
I'm going to let you connect the dots on
that one
so without further Ado I just want to
Welcome to the screen with me
a man who has a Bachelor of Science in
agriculture looking at the plants
that led him into
being a doctor of veterinary medicine
looking at the body the systems how
everything works that led him into three
post-doctorates and pathology going
deeper at looking at those systems
what's happening when something's
missing
and then on to being a naturopathic
physician where he then became able to
treat
people folks take his research which is
actually held in the National Institute
the Smithsonian National Institute in
Washington DC as a National Treasure
and take that information because it
correlated with mankind as well to help
us you and I folks not just our pets
which he loves also we love also
but mankind period so Dr Joel Wallach it
is my honor and privilege to be able to
share you with the world on
so many platforms thanks to AJ
well thank you AJ for getting us on a
wider platform we can't thank you enough
for that and that's going to get the
information out there obviously to
Greater number of people which is our
desire save as many lives as we can and
thank you to Rebecca as usual for
getting everything started and set up
today
and today we want to do something a
little special we want to talk about a
specific tissue of the body we want to
talk about something that most people
don't think about too much is called the
gallbladder okay the gallbladder okay
and well that's something that they
think is dispensable
something's not working right just take
out the gallbladder right well doctors
do that all the time well we were in
there we just took out your gallbladders
we won't have to worry about in the
future blah blah blah blah uh it's very
very bad uh the capacity of the
gallbladder is anywhere from one ounce
to almost three ounces to 2.7 ounces of
bile
and bile has several functions
um but when you eat something you get
messages sent all over the place
including the liver and liver tells your
gallbladder to contract and when it
contracts it squirts that bile have been
building up since the previous meal okay
squirts in the intestine and the
function of the bile is to help you
efficiently absorb
um fatty tissues we're talking about fat
sample vitamins a d e and K and we're
talking about
um uh the fats the essential fatty acids
uh okay uh essential fatty acids is
including the uh
omegas and Omega-3s which are part of
the uh it's a structure of cell walls
okay many enzymes and so uh imperatives
that you have these uh um nutrients to
maintain and rebuild and new tissues and
so forth and the gallbladder is required
to pull all that off
now when you think about it
again you know just a little less than
three ounces we're looking at a
gallbladder with a volume capacity to
that of about the volume of a golf ball
okay
and it's so important to life
to get all these essential nutrients
absorbed into the bloodstream so they go
to the proper places and function
and
the
um gallbladder is a is this little bag
okay it's a very thin bag so it expands
when it starts filling up with by also
the liquid and it has a smoothie muscle
in there so it gets it when it gets the
electric signals that there's
um food you know this being digested in
the stomach and the duodenum
so it squirts the bile into the duodenum
so you can absorb all the
fat soluble stuff it's necessary for
life and and energy and function and so
forth protection your body defenses and
you want you to think about how much
fatty tissues in the brain how many
fatty tissues
are in our sex hormones and so forth all
this kind of stuff so the gallbladder is
in a position
of I like to say essentiality although
you can you can you can struggle along
and you can live without the gallbladder
but instead of you know accumulating
three ounces of bottle at a time to
squirt into your duodenum you'll be
getting a drop drop drop drop drop
and that's less effective than having a
Big Blob of bile coming in to your
duodenum she can absorbables nutrients
they're associated with um the need for
bile
so it's one of those things where you
know when the doctor says you know I'm
going in there uh you got something
going on with your appendix while I'm in
there you want me to take out your
gallbladder and most people say sure go
ahead and take it out no don't do that
okay you want that gallbladder it has
very very important
um functions
and um when you look at the
it's kind of interesting that uh
I don't think horses have gallbladders
okay calcium gallbladders
and of course we do have a an enzyme we
have an enzyme okay product called
ultimate enzyme I call it the
gallbladder in a bottle because what we
do we go to the to the places where they
till cattle you know and make steaks out
of them and they sent the other but they
also will take the gallbladders off the
livers
um of these cattle and give them to us
they don't give them to it they sell
them to us and
we take the bile out of there and dry
dry the bile and then we put the bile in
our
in our um the essential
um enzymes okay and we call it the
gallbladder
uh in a in a bottle okay and it is one
of those things where the bile okay the
center enzymes helps you absorb more
essential nutrients then you just and
you would be able to do with just plain
enzymes
so he called the gallbladder in a bottle
and um it's our ultimate enzymes and I
take the two or three of those being my
meal no less than two often times three
of the ultimate enzymes say five or ten
minutes for each meal and that way I'm
able to absorb all these essential fatty
acids that have to do
with the presence of the bile okay so
this is very important stuff
um it's a small tissue when a cab comes
to say 150 pound to 200 pound person
we're talking about
just the empty gallbladder that doesn't
even weigh an ounce okay but it is so
important because it delivers an
important substance the bile into the
intestines at the right moment so you
can absorb all these essential fatty
acids that make up portions of the walls
every cell in the body
every cell in the body the walls are
made up of essential fatty acids okay
and of course hormones are made up of
essential fatty acids you do not want to
be without
essential fatty acids okay and so um and
it prevents abnormal blood clots okay
the bile prevents abnormal blood clots
you don't get strokes and so you know
you start talking about all the things
that it does that gallbladder is one of
your best friends
so um I rarely talk about it okay
because most people
gallbladder can I buy one no
um
I think you probably could get a
transplant a gallbladder but uh I I've
heard that but it's one of those things
where just don't um take your
gallbladder okay because it's so
essential all right with that back over
to you Becca
all right thank you so much Dr Wallach
so bio is needed to break down the fats
including those in our essential fatty
acids and absorb them
essential fatty acids omegas Omega-3s
and because they make up the walls of
every cell of your body regardless of
what type of tissue it is so those
things require the bile and the only way
you're going to get enough to absorb
maximum amounts of the bile is to have a
gallbladder skin accumulated during the
day
as the liver makes it
okay it saves it in in the gallbladder
and you take that whole part of the
digestive system out
and then it's like
you're you're
you're just taken away from the body's
ability to break down the food and then
absorb that's correct
so how I don't understand and and this
is just you know throwing it out there I
don't understand how anybody would make
sense of that other than not having the
knowledge in the importance of the
gallbladder
well I appreciate that the medical
system looks at the gallbladder
as an accessory
tissue okay now your liver still makes
bile if you take out your gallbladder
but it doesn't accumulate in any large
amounts such as drip drip drip drip all
day okay and so you're getting a lot of
wasted bile clothes going down in your
intestines when there's you know no meal
there are no food there and so it just
kind of goes away before the food gets
here and so and since
um uh and of course when the doctor says
you know while I'm in there
um and you know I really can't find
anything else wrong but let's let's take
your gallbladder out
and the question you have to ask the
doctor is do you have a kid in college
and you know it's it's hard to
comprehend Dr Wallach because there is
that Hippocratic Oath that doctors take
and doing no harm
well
my next question Dr Wallach you know
with the gallbladder and taking it
taking it out
then
you know is just doing the old
the product the doctor that Dr Wallach
just mentioned
um is that enough or do we have to be
intentional about the foods that we are
putting in our body
well you definitely have to be
intentional about the foods within your
body but also
um you want to whether you have your
gallbladder or has been taken out you
want to take our ultimate enzymes which
we call a gallbladder in a bottle so
it's actually helping you accumulate
those things required by your liver to
make bile so it's already got the bile
in there and so it's kind of like again
it's a gallbladder in a bottle uh I take
two or three of those about 10 minutes
for every meal
and um
it's one of those things where uh again
I'm
um 84 years old and you know
most people think you know I'm in my 50s
or 60s I can't believe I'm 84 because my
energy I'm not in any prescription drugs
I don't have anything I certainly don't
have any digestion problems I have you
know really normal scheduled bowel
movements and all that kind of stuff
and so it's not like I have to take
drugs to have a bowel movement so I
don't I have to take enemas to have a
bowel movement and all that kind of
stuff as many people do okay and so we
need to talk to those people because
there's a piece in the puzzle missing
when they have to have a bowel movement
every night okay so they can have a you
know have an enema every night so they
can have a bowel movement before they go
to bed that's there's something wrong
there
or even take different lacks such as Dr
Wallach I know some people that I've
worked with they'll say oh I have a
couple of a week
a couple bowel movements a week and like
how many times do you eat a week
oh I eat three four times a day
well
Common Sense folks
food coming in It's gotta come out
it can't just be backed up because what
happens Dr Wallach whenever you have a
lot of fecal matter that is built up
into the intestines not working through
I mean our food is not pure there are
toxins in it
so what happens with the the stuff
that's backed up that just sits there
does that cause harm
well it sits there but it also releases
bad stuff toxins it goes to your brain
and your heart and your lungs and your
liver and your kidneys and your muscles
and your bones your bone marrow and all
this kind of stuff so there's a global
um negative that's going on inside your
body
okay when you have those kinds of issues
and so that's why we came up with the
gallbladder in a bottle and of course
um they love us in these slaughterhouses
and they save the gallbladders as far as
in the beginning we used to clean them
ourselves and then but after a while the
bigger the bigger
um
facilities they you know they put a
ligature around the bile duct so it
doesn't leak all the bile out because we
want the bile we don't want the
gallbladder we want the bottle tend to
gallbladder so they put a little tie on
it and snug it up so it doesn't leak
everything and when we come there we get
a bucket full of gallbladders that have
you know two to three ounces of biolum
so I wanna I wanna do a disclosure here
Dr Wallach okay is we don't just go in
with some bucket and collect stuff
it's coming from animals that are
cleanly fed in a sterile environment
where everything is processed and
they're put into sterile containers with
proper transportation and everything is
protected
they're inspected because they wouldn't
let to be used for human food if there's
anything wrong any disease in those cows
and steers and stuff like that and
calves and so it's it's inspected you
know it's not like we're going to the
garbage dump so they're throwing all
this stuff in we're collecting the
gallbladders these
um animals when they're slaughtered are
inspected okay by federal
agents okay to make sure there's no
disease in them and so we're getting
guaranteed no disease in those
gallbladders
yes so I just wanted to make sure that
we had that clear that it's not just
coming from any and every animal that
walks through the slaughterhouse folks
the nice thing that I like about the
enzymes Dr Wallach is it also includes
and it's the ultimate enzymes it
includes enzymes that help to break down
the proteins the carbohydrates and the
fats also in addition to that oxfile
that is to it to help the body whether
we're not making enough bile or no
gallbladder and it's just not being
admitted like it was or the body was
designed to have so thank you so much
for that information about the
gallbladder Dr Wallach I want to make
sure that we do get to people who have
questions and as I'm going through here
YouTube Raphael has a question he says I
got a question for Doc
um he wants to know what are phytates
and what foods contain them
and if we should avoid them because of
side effects
um so Dr Wallach I know that's not in
relation to gallbladder but do you want
to touch on phytates real quick
okay well if I chase are kind of
connect connective tissue
um fiber stuff okay chemicals that
interfere uh with the absorption of
stuff okay
um it interferes with the absorptive
surfaces and your intestines and so
forth and the more fibrous the food you
eat the more fights that you get so
people who are vegetarians are eating a
lot of phytates because they're eating
all this plant material okay so they're
getting a lot of phytates
okay and um on one hand they can absorb
toxins and help you take them out the
other end
but also they take up
nutrients as well as if you're on
prescription medication they will absorb
a lot of the prescription medications
and take it out the other end so you're
not getting full benefit of the
prescription medication
oh interesting okay well I haven't heard
that part
so thank you so much for that and
Pauline has a question in regards to
mitochondria
how do toxins get into the mitochondria
and cause issues okay well mitochondria
our instructors inside of cells that
actually create energy
okay that's their purpose is to produce
energy so you know when you eat sugar
and carbohydrates and fats and
everything you say well I'm eating all
this for energy well it's got to go
through the through the
um
through the various
portions of the cells okay
and so it's one of those things where
um
the mitochondria is that we're talking
about here right that's right the
mitochondria or where energy is produced
okay from what you eat
all right thank you so much for that Dr
Wallach and we have a question from
Courtney and she wants to know about
fecal transplant Dr Wallach while we're
talking about digestion
fecal transplant and wants to know if it
will do anything beneficial for ra
is specifically what she's wanting to
know about well first of all ra
rheumatoid arthritis has two factors too
number one is just simple nutritional
deficiency arthritis it has a secondary
infection okay with a bug called
mycoplasma which is killable with an
antibody called Minocycline like a
little Bait fish minnow minnow cycling
and I can take somebody who's had
rheumatoid arthritis for 40 years
and in less than 30 days they don't have
rheumatoid arthritis anymore because we
put them on the healthy Bone and Joint
pack we'd get them on middle cycling and
we the healthy Bone and Joint pack that
rebuilds the actual bones and cartilage
and ligaments and tendons and throw in
that I think throwing the um MSM and
throw in the collagen peptides it'll be
faster or more complete but then also
um you have to understand that the
antibiotic is required because
rheumatoid arthritis is a infection with
a bug called mycoplasma
all right thank you so much for that
explanation
doctors want to believe that that room
turns tries to autoimmune disease your
body's attacking itself that falls into
the science of crapola
so would that fall under why they would
consider a fecal transplant I mean
that's like messing up that person's
that's because I think it's an
autoimmune thing and they want
somebody's immune system from somebody
else to help deal with that probably
this immune problem okay well I rather
take an antibody called middle cycling
than have somebody's poop put into me
okay
that's kind of gross
somebody else's species feces
interesting yum yum
no
uh yeah at least okay so James here is
asking a question in regards to the
gallbladder Dr Bullock and prone to
gallstones the doctors are wanting to
remove it so we have a gentleman here
who's 200 pounds at five or six foot two
prone to gallstones okay one what causes
gallstones
okay no stones
sometimes in the liver and there's you
know the size of a pea or smaller and
they kind of go down all the bile ducts
and they wind up in the gallbladder any
kind of stuff sometimes a wind up in the
common bile duck which is from the
gallbladder in the intestines and can
cause the gallbladder to fill up with
more than normal bile it could be
uncomfortable and so forth well here's a
case where the 90 essential nutrients to
make sure that the liver is getting
everything it needs to function properly
I would go ahead and get the
um
gallbladder in a bottle the ultimate
enzymes go ahead and take two or three
of those five or timids for each meal
you sure you're taking the I'd go ahead
of the full package the healthy grain
and heart pack
we really probably should call it the
healthy brain liver and heart pack okay
we could also say that the healthy brain
and liver and heart and lung and
intestine a kidney pack okay because it
deals with all these tissues and organs
and things
and doctors tend to pick one cell or
they'll pick one organ
um and so forth and that's why they do
so many surgeries and things
as opposing to get getting to the basic
uh program that's been disrupted because
of nutritional deficiency or a poisoning
or something or combinations of that and
so
um
when you have gallstones taking your
gallbladder out is the wrong solution
wrong that's not the way to solve the
problem you want to find out why those
gallstones are accumulating in in the
gallbladder okay the gallbladder not may
not be getting the signals to push out
the bottle okay
um or may have other deficiencies that
are causing the muscles in the
gallbladder and the muscles in the pile
ducts to not be working properly
all right and so there's all kinds of
possibilities here and so I like to when
somebody has gallstones
you know you got got to treat the whole
body including the bile ducts and the
gallbladder and and the biliary tissues
which are in the in the liver which
brings the bile down into the
gallbladder okay and so all that has to
be dealt with if you're going to deal
properly with gallstones just taking
your gallbladder out
is like saying well I have a headache
I'm just going to shoot myself in the
head that'll take care of it oh yeah it
will but you won't like the long-term
effect
so the the gallbladder is basically just
a bag that holds these Stones that's
right or else the gallbladder is just a
bag that holds the bile
and if there's if there's gall stones
coming down and a little biliary tubes
from the liver and they'll plop into
your gallbladder and if your gallbladder
for one reason another it doesn't have
either the signal or the ability or
because of blockages and the common bile
duct because you have maybe liver
cirrhosis squeezing it or you know
there's all kinds of possibilities here
and this is where an MRI would help oh
she can you know none it's an MRIs the
um
the the body's ability to tell you the
story okay
um without having to do an x-ray okay
it's it has to do
with um
the magnetic yeah yeah it's a magnetic
thing
and so you can see the tissues actually
as you see a much better definition of
soft tissue uh with MRI than you do an
x-ray when you do when you do an x-ray
of the skull you always see the big
black hole which sounded by the skull
but when you do an MRI you see all the
wrinkles in the in the brain and of the
pituitary gland you see all that stuff
so an MRI can be extremely useful in
these issues
all right thank you so
you so much well let's go ahead and give
uh this gentleman what the protocol
would be
complete
as a solution and folks if you refer to
this program by somebody specific make
sure that you get back with that person
to get these products don't go searching
on the internet somewhere because you
don't know if you're getting one
actual product to within date or have
you know we want to make sure that
you're getting quality product that has
not been sitting in somebody's Warehouse
or sitting in a hot shelf that then
compromises the products and two most
importantly to make sure that what
you're getting are Act is actually true
youngevity products so get back with the
person that shared this program with you
if there's nobody to think you may go to
daily with doc.com and we do have a
store that will have all of the products
Dr Wallach is about to mention so Dr
Wallach protocol four gentlemen six foot
two two hundred pounds having Stones
okay so it needs to give everyone the
bad foods no fried foods no processed
Meats no oils no glutens the Wheaton oh
so sugar no carbon or drinks you know
the diet drinks need to go as well as a
carbonated waters the 200 pounds of
women have two healthy brain and heart
attacks a month a full load everything
twice a day for liver function and
kidney function and heart function
intestinal function whole thing brain
function
now we also need them to have uh two
bottles a month of the MSM so they take
three breakfasts lunch at dinner time
and they're going to support and promote
manage repair of cartilage ligaments
tendons connective tissue disk between
himself
also need the uh let's see here the
um
the colonies here the collagen okay the
cup the collagen peptides want them to
have uh two canisters a month so you
take a scoop without this morning drinks
whether this evening drink it's going to
again help build the connective tissue
in the liver and the gallbladder and
bile ducts and so forth then of course
you need to have
the uh let's see here I would also throw
in the synaptive three of those twice a
day so that the nerve cells can talk to
the gallbladder and the liver okay and
then we want
um we want all this to uh
go on of course the ultimate enzymes
take two or three of those say five or
ten minutes before each meal with a
couple ounces of water
and there's a cigar blender in a bottle
it's going to help
um do the function of the gallbladder do
not take the gallbladder out okay and
then get back to us in a couple of weeks
and let us know what's going on
and um because if you give your liver
everything it needs it will not make any
more gallstones when you're making
gallstones it means your liver is being
cheated or something it's not getting
everything at once
absolutely now Dr willick I know that
there there are some practices when
people are having problems with
digestion
um or the gallbladder or different
things like constipation that they
actually there's a procedure that
actually goes in and cuts the vagus
nerve
what's what's the hazards of cutting a
vagus nerve what what would be the
benefits of it okay well the biggest
nerve is cranial nerve number 10 it's
formed in the brain comes down goes all
the way down into your stomach and when
you have the skull squeezing the 10th
Trail nerve you get all kinds of stuff
going on okay
um you get irregular heartbeat it um
atrial fibrillation doctors think it's a
heart issue notice the 10th cream
they're being squeezed by the skull and
also gives slow heart rate which is
bradycardia you can also get a fast
heart rate tachycardia and also get a
terrible pain in your stomach doctors oh
you got an ulcer and it's really the
tensional nerve and it's called
gastroparesis look up gastroparesis okay
g-a-s-t-r-o
um P I think it's p-o-r-e-s r a
s-i-s okay there you go thank you
gastroparesis okay
okay and so that's the pain in the
stomach that's the tense cranial nerve
which starts in the brain and you know
you don't want to be cutting that nerve
okay because then you'll have trouble
with digestion and absorption you have
pain uh all this kind of stuff you do
not want to cut that nerve
well I have a girlfriend Dr Wallach that
before she knew me uh before she knew
that there were other options she had
her gallbladder removed they
accidentally cut that vagus nerve and
now she's going through hell
just always in pain always having
problems with
with anything moving through our system
so folks
be real careful when they want start
talking about cutting on anything
make sure that you have all the facts
all of the options and ask them well is
there a natural option
is there another approach to this
without having to do surgery that's why
we're here so you can ask questions like
that so we can give them you know the
options
and absolutely
thank you okay so we have another
question Dr Wallach and this has to do
with I think sunburn
second-degree burns
um what is good to get my color back on
my legs I got
burned oh 60 of on my legs second degree
burns
um
60 years old 160 pounds no health or 170
pounds and no other health conditions so
something cost burning on this on this
lady's skin Dr Wallach is there anything
you can do to support the skin and be
able to one if it's recent help it to to
not be so painful quicker
the two restore color
well first of all
never wanted something awesome
sun blocker on she must be a blonde
blonde well I'm wondering because you
could get second degree burns from from
boiling water too
yeah
and then unless she said boiling water
because it just says Burns it doesn't
say she got burnt sixty percent on her
legs
okay well in any case she's here with
all the bad foods no fried foods no
processed Meats no oils no glutens the
wheat and bar Ryan oats no no buckwheat
no sugar no carbonated drinks even the
diet drinks and the carbonated water
need to go 170 pounds she needs to have
two healthy branded heart pressure month
photos showing twice a day
then she needs two miles a month the MSM
should take three a break with a
straight line straight to dinner time to
give the skin the raw materials it needs
to rebuild itself then she needs the
collagen peptides two of those canisters
from other so you take a scoop without
their morning drinks whether they're
eating drink again to help the body
repair the
um skin cheese Hair Skin and Nails take
three of those if it says terrible
second degree burns I'd ever take three
of the of the um
let's see here uh three of those Hair
Skin and Nails three times a day so
these are small bottles so it'd be three
of those little bottles a month take
three breakfasts free lunch or dinner
time and then of course we have all
kinds of skin
um things okay will help the skin when
it comes to relieving
um itching and pain and all that kind of
stuff the same cream uh we'll do that
okay where she had put on her joints or
her back her belly wherever she has the
worst places of the pain on the same
cream does wonders for about anywhere
from depending on the degree of damage
um we're talking about two to four hours
of discomfort Relief pain relief okay it
doesn't fix anything but it does give
you pain relief while you're healing
okay and so the CM cream is not a
healing thing but it does relieve the
pain so you can function during the day
while you are healing so I hope that
helps yes so Dr Wallach I know you
weren't looking at my face but for those
that were watching the program saw a
change in my face as I was just shared a
picture of what this individual's legs
look like and it's pretty in intensive
Dr Wallach so
um
a AJ is sharing this from I think
YouTube
um so for the person that's going
through this please make sure that you
get a hold of us through daily
withdoc.com I will then share this
information this picture with Dr Wallach
and what he gave you is absolutely the
foundation and I think spray and plant
Drive minerals directly on the skin Dr
Wallach can go a long ways in this
situation as well
cannot hurt because of this plant
minerals are a great healer and we've we
have some great stories of people who
were you know within minutes of dying
according to doctors and we just rubbed
the plant derived minerals on them the
liquids okay and three days later
they're perfectly normal
well and as I'm getting in for more
information here this is the this is the
aftermath of a house fire so so thankful
that you made it out of that house fire
hopefully no one else was injured
um
my ass batter worse than you so we
definitely are here to help us with that
as well
oh goodness so Dr Wallach
as I'm going through and I have more and
more questions I have somebody that's
wanting to know about the appendix
is that does it work like the
gallbladder is it something that's
needed also
well the good Lord gives an appendix and
now that does have to do with your
immune system it has to do with white
blood cells and so forth and antibodies
um
and so uh it actually helped protect you
I mean when you think about it your your
colon is full of all the bad bacteria
and viruses and all kinds of bad stuff
poisons and things and so or the small
intestine hooks into the large intestine
the good lord gave us an appendix to
kind of be a
um a filter okay to protect you from a
lot of bad stuff okay poisons uh
types of chemicals that are produced by
the body by infections and so forth so
your appendix is part of your immune
system now when you have appendicitis
and it ruptures it's time to have it
removed okay
um and so this is where I like the MRI
because it'll tell you a lot about your
appendix as opposed to an x-ray
um because you can see the details of
the outside and the inside emphatics and
the the doctor can make an educated
determination does this panics need to
be removed
okay or is it okay uh you know we that's
where an MRI will be able to help you
make that determination okay because
there's no radiation in it as as one of
the values of it but also another value
is it's very very detailed in soft
tissue where and where an x-ray is not
okay
well and people usually don't think
about the appendix unless there is a
secret well it's painful it's painful
everybody knows oh down my lower right
you know quadrant theorem my or my
appendix is they always know where their
appendix is s on the right side okay and
so this is not difficult you don't need
to be a doctor to figure out you have
something going on with your appendix we
have pain down there okay well and then
and for me Dr Walo it was more than pain
it was pain it was vomiting
I and ended up going in for emergency if
um appendectomy because it had burst so
you know you don't think about these
things
you know what are we putting into our
bodies that could be the actual cause of
poor health conditions situations that
lead into an emergency situation okay
what leads into an appendicitis gluten
alert buckwheat gluten alert buckwheat
gluten alert buckwheat okay I wasn't
doing any buckwheat but I was grinding
my own weed I was making my own breads
my own cinnamon rolls all of these baked
goods
gluten alert gluten alert gluten alert
gluten alert and that's why your
appendix wasn't happy okay and
um when it gets so unhappy it will burst
okay just like when you have a heart
attack kind of thing when your heart's
unhappy it'll go so far and then it will
burst get ruptured aneurysms all kinds
of stuff okay and appendix is no
different
okay and so it's one of those things
where
what makes it dangerous when it ruptures
it spills all these bacteria and viruses
into your belly cavity okay which can be
fatal
yeah we don't want to go there spokes
prevention is so much better than
reaction especially if you react too
late well Dr Wallach it is time for you
to go on to the next program as you have
a very busy schedule at your 84 years so
thank you so much for joining us here on
daily with Doc and if I could get my
co-hosts on with me man we cannot do a
production like this without the support
of many people we have Marilyn pazera
which fears if you are here live with us
in the zoom and you have that chat on
you see how valuable her work is as she
is taking and doing dictation of what Dr
Wallach is saying within the program the
questions that are being asked she is
putting that right there in the meeting
chat and because of HIPAA violations
which we do not want to even consider
being part of that and information is
not
shared on our live streams so that's one
benefit of being here if you're here
live with us and you do have your
question answered or a similar situation
compared to something you or someone you
know loves know and love has you are can
able to do a screenshot or use your
phone and take a picture of that so that
you can take that to your coach or the
person that referred you to this program
or your future coach if you don't have
one and say hey I have this protocol
that Dr Wallach gave on daily with Doc
and it sounds like something I need to
get to can you help me get it
you can reach somebody if you're not
working with somebody already on our
website on that contact option and send
us an email with the protocol that you
took the screenshot off of and we'll
make sure that we get you a program that
is that best fits your situation
um or you can call us at
855-949-3377 again this is for people
who are not currently working with
somebody not referred to this program by
somebody specific who is
um one of our family when it comes to
our family of coaches and Associates who
promote the work that Dr Wallach does
and has done and perform his formulas
okay
um we want to make sure that our
resource to them
stays intact with Integrity that way and
then we have Miss Sherry and Sherry is
making sure that everybody gets into the
zoom quickly and make sure that if they
have their camera on everything is
kosher with what is being seen in the
camera and that is for the safety of our
whole entire audience that is here live
with us and then we have AJ who's
watching all these different platforms
all these different screens now making
sure that the message is getting where
it's supposed to be without
interruptions and if something happens
he makes it important
so I could not do this without AJ and
thank you again AJ for taking us from
three platforms to we're gonna have to
do an actual count
um but it is over a dozen and it is all
because of
a team working together with their
strengths
for the greater purpose
so folks if you have strengths that you
would like to contribute to something
that's worthwhile something that
promotes life that promotes Wellness
that promotes not just Wellness
physically mentally emotionally
spiritually but also financially
make sure you get back with the person
that shared this program with you or
send us an email or call us at
855-949-3377 and let us know hey I want
to be part of this Crusade that Dr
Wallach has started in
having to to make the world a better
place all around because think about it
if we are sick and miserable
our outward Expressions to people around
us is going to be sick and miserable and
then that forwards on to the people
they're around because they've been made
miserable
so if we're all functioning and happy
and healthy and then that beams out
to those around us that bring beans out
to those around them then there's no
other way but to be a happier place
so let's go spread some sunshine thank
you so much for joining us here on daily
with Doc again my name is Becca dukes
and if you would like to get more
information about our coaching program
that we have through the Institute of
holistic health it is open to anybody
and everybody as long as you have
internet connections you can plug into
the coursework at The Institute of
holistic health and become a certified
holistic health coach where you are
learning about the four areas of Health
how they're affected by nutrient
deficiencies and then also the solutions
folks you can find out more information
at
coachwithdoc.com that is coachwith Doc
doc.com until next time bye for now oh I
forgot to mention
hold on AJ don't I did this to him
yesterday and he stopped it before I was
done because he's like on it
um folks we're here Monday through
Friday from 12 to 12 50 p.m Pacific time
so if you would like to join us live in
our Zoom room please do so by going to
daily with Doc zoom.com that is daily
with Doc zoom.com
bye for now
record
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]